on Tuesday the opposition control
legislator starts the impeachment
process against the conservative
president bringing to a boil a long
simmering political crisis
your position believes it has the Super
majority of 92 out of 137 votes required
to remove the former Banker as president
his administration has been besieged by
scandals deteriorating economic
conditions and a tide of drug-related
killings
ecuadorians on the streets are as
divided as ever I think he should go in
a democratic and legal way the Congress
is representing the will of the people
this government has only destroyed our
health and education systems
lasso should finish his term the people
18 million ecuadorians voted and he won
a majority we should let him finish his
work
lasso is accused of corruption related
to the embezzlement of funds and
contracts signed with a state oil
Transfer Company
his supporters deny the charges
describing them as politically motivated
this would be nothing short of a
parliamentarian coup they're trying to
remove him with strained far-fetched
evidence remember that this contract was
signed in 2018 by the previous
government investigators have found no
penal responsibility so there can't be a
political one
the leading impeachment congresswoman
says that this is just one of a series
of corruption allegations surrounding
the president's Inner Circle and it has
become a referendum on his government
this is no coup we're not trying to
destabilize the country its responds to
a demand by citizens A desperate clamor
for a constitutional solution to a
problem called Guillermo lasso the polls
showed that after the issue of security
the biggest problem for ecuadorians is
lasso as president lasso said he will
appear before Congress to defend himself
but he also vowed to dissolve Congress
and call for early elections against the
impeachment vote triggering A peculiar
constitutional Clause known as Mutual
debt that has never been used before oi
if that is triggered lasso will remain
in office for another six months
governing by decree but analysts Fiora
could spark further protest similar to
those last year over the rising costs of
living and further instability would
rock a country already adrift I is
we can now bring in Alessandro joining
us once again from Quito so talk us
through How likely it is that lhasa will
be impeached
without
[Music]
it well as we speak uh we are listening
to lasso inside the National Assembly
forcefully rejecting the charges denying
the charges denying any uh wrongdoing he
is insisting that uh he is here to
defend he said the dignity and the honor
of his government which he says is an
honest government and an efficient one
and that is also here to defend the
dreams he said of ecuadorians who voted
for him yet what it also is clear is
that he's a very unpopular uh president
polls have him around 17 percent
approval rating and that there is a
majority in Congress that would like to
see him remove the question is if there
is a the super majority needed to do so
that would be 92 of the 137 assembly
members are two-thirds of the National
Assembly here if you talk to the
opposition they'll tell you that indeed
they have those number but it's quite
unclear at this point and the vote could
be a number of days from now most likely
on Saturday or next week so things could
still change
um
substantially yeah Alessandro and lasso
himself could also decide to dissolve
Congress and call for early elections to
avoid being sacked
[Music]
clause and Ecuador's Constitution that
allows the president to do that during
his first three years in power Alaska's
been in power for a little over two
years and now so it could indeed do that
uh it is he has said he has vowed to do
that if indeed he understand that it
could be removed from office there's
also a third scenario that is being
rumored or that is growing here which is
the possibility that he decides to
resign before an eventual vote leaving
the Vice President in power for the next
two years if you talk to analysts here
they'll tell you that that would be in
many ways the less traumatic decision at
this point given the fact that lasso
hasn't been able or unwilling to
negotiate any of his agenda with
Congress so we're gonna have to see what
happens in in coming days but what's
clear is that lasso wants to fight light
and try to remain in office all right
thank you so much Alessandro and Petty
reporting from crito